This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So a quick announcement before we start. Earlier this year, I went to the TED conference in Vancouver and I gave a talk about flag design. It was an incredible experience and even though there was a little bit of skepticism when I started the talk, you know when everyone Learned that it was really going to be about flag design. The talk totally won over the crowd and I got a standing ovation. It was a real highlight of my career and last week the video was finally released. So I really hope everyone who listens to the show will go watch it and share it. You're gonna dig it. The cool part is that let me perform the talk like a radio piece instead of the normal TED talk. I'm sitting down and playing audio clips and talking over music, and for once you get to, you know, see my face while I do it.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在开始之前先做一个简短的公告。今年早些时候，我去了温哥华的TED大会，做了一场关于旗帜设计的演讲。那是一次不可思议的经历，尽管我刚开始演讲时大家还有点怀疑，你知道的，当大家得知这真的是关于旗帜设计时。但这场演讲完全征服了观众，我获得了全场起立鼓掌。这是我职业生涯中的一个真正亮点，上周视频终于发布了。所以我真心希望每一位收听节目的听众都能去观看并分享它。你会喜欢的。最酷的部分是，我得以像表演广播节目一样进行演讲，而不是普通的TED演讲。我坐着播放音频片段，在音乐声中讲述，而且这一次，你可以在我演讲时看到我的脸。
If you've been listening to 99% of visible for a while, you know that one of the thorns in my side is the city flag of San Francisco. If you're not familiar with that flag, you'll see it in the video. It's not good. Anyway, 99PI has some fans at the company Autodesk, and if you don't know Autodesk, all you need to know is this, if the thing you're looking at exists in three dimensions in the real world, that object was probably designed on Autodesk software. So Autodesk has this big office in San Francisco, and they saw all the TED Talk and suggested
如果你听《99%隐形》有一段时间了，你就会知道我的一块心病是旧金山市旗。如果你不熟悉那面旗帜，你会在视频中看到它。它确实不怎么样。总之，《99%隐形》在Autodesk公司有一些粉丝，如果你不知道Autodesk，你只需要知道这一点：如果你所看到的东西在现实世界中以三维形式存在，那么该物体很可能就是用Autodesk软件设计的。所以Autodesk在旧金山有一个大办公室，他们看到了TED演讲，并建议
that we partner together to help plan a redesign of the San Francisco flag. I'm really excited. We have a website, San Francisco Flag.com, you can watch the TED Talk there, sign up, learn more, get involved, that's San Francisco Flag.com. Please visit, watch the video, share the link, I'm trying to get my TED Talk to become the most watched TED Talk in history, so we just need 33 million more views to get there. So if each of you who download the show, watch the video between 16-70 times. We can make it, or you can just share it a lot and make your friends watch it. Alright, thanks so much. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars.
我们合作，共同规划旧金山市旗的重新设计。我非常兴奋。我们有一个网站，SanFranciscoFlag.com，你可以在那里观看TED演讲、注册、了解更多信息并参与其中，网址是SanFranciscoFlag.com。请访问、观看视频、分享链接，我正努力让我的TED演讲成为历史上观看次数最多的TED演讲，所以我们还需要3300万次观看才能达到目标。所以，如果每一位下载节目的听众都能观看视频16到70次，我们就能做到，或者你也可以多分享一下，让你的朋友们也看看。好了，非常感谢。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。
The office of the Cheek Medical Examiner in Baltimore, Maryland is a busy place. Anyone who dies unexpectedly in the state of Maryland will end up there for an autopsy. On an average day, they might perform 12 autopsy's. On a heavier day, they might do more than 20. The building is six stories tall. Around 80 people are employed there. All day long, fleets are coming in and out. People are calling about their deceased loved ones.
马里兰州巴尔的摩市的首席法医办公室是一个繁忙的地方。任何在马里兰州意外死亡的人最终都会被送到那里进行尸检。平均每天，他们可能会进行12次尸检。在忙碌的日子里，他们可能会做超过20次。这座建筑有六层楼高。大约有80人在那里工作。整天都有灵车进进出出。人们打来电话询问他们去世的亲人。
The press is calling with inquiries. But there's this one room on the fourth floor that sits apart from the buzz of normal activity in the building. Producer Katie Mingle was just there in Baltimore. This room feels a bit more like an art gallery because well it is kind of an art gallery. It houses the nutshell studies, which are these miniature doll house-like dioramas, and each one is a different scene. There's a kitchen, a log cabin, a barn, a bathroom. There are 18 different scenes. And each scene has different tiny features,
媒体打来电话询问情况。但在四楼有一个房间，它远离大楼里正常的喧嚣。制片人凯蒂·明格尔刚刚去过巴尔的摩。这个房间感觉更像是一个艺术画廊，因为，嗯，它确实算是一个艺术画廊。它收藏了“坚果壳研究”，这些是微型的、像玩偶屋一样的立体模型，每一个都是不同的场景。有厨房、小木屋、谷仓、浴室。共有18个不同的场景。每个场景都有不同的微小特征，
tiny furniture, tiny windows and doors and lamps, and there are also tiny people, dolls in each scene, and all of the tiny people in these scenes have one thing in common. They're all dead. When you look at a nutshell diorama, you're looking for clues about how the person or person's died. Was it a suicide, a homicide, an accidental death? The guns there. You're obviously going to get a lot of evidence off the gun. So why would
微小的家具、微小的窗户、门和灯，每个场景里还有微小的人，即玩偶，而这些场景中所有微小的人都有一个共同点。他们都死了。当你观察一个坚果壳立体模型时，你是在寻找关于那个人或那些人是如何死亡的线索。是自杀、他杀还是意外死亡？枪在那里。你显然会从枪上获得很多证据。那么为什么
someone that came into murder them? Why would they leave a gun if they knew that that's going to happen? So I said a minute ago that the nutshell room is usually a quiet sanctuary and an otherwise busy office. And it is usually. But this week there are quite a few people in here. They're mostly police, a few FBI, and they're here for a week-long seminar on homicide investigation. While they're there, the attendees will hear speakers, they'll see an autopsy, and they'll be broken into groups and assigned a nutshell diorama. At the end of the week, they'll be asked to present their theories of what happened in their dioramas.
有人进来谋杀他们？如果他们知道会发生这种情况，为什么要留下一把枪？所以我刚才说，坚果壳房间通常是一个繁忙办公室里的安静避难所。它通常确实如此。但本周这里有相当多的人。他们大多是警察，还有几位FBI，他们是来参加为期一周的凶杀案调查研讨会的。在他们待在那里期间，与会者将听取演讲，观看尸检，并被分成小组，分配到一个坚果壳立体模型。在周末，他们将被要求展示他们对模型中发生的事情的理论。
This group is looking at one of the few multi-room nutshell studies. And then he stumbles in here. He's crawling at this point, gets in the bed, and then falls, and that's where he dies. But he drags the comfort under him. You might have thrown him off beforehand. Now most nutshells are just one room
这组人正在观察少数几个多房间的坚果壳研究模型之一。然后他跌跌撞撞地走进这里。此时他正在爬行，爬上床，然后倒下，这就是他死亡的地方。但他把毯子拖到了身下。你可能之前把他扔掉了。现在大多数坚果壳模型只有一个房间，
and about the size of a shoe box. This one is a little bigger. It has three rooms plus a porch. It's in a glass case, so you can look down and see the interior of the house from above. He doesn't check the round until it comes into the baby's room. I think there's a lot of room. The scene is of a lovely well-kept suburban home.
大约鞋盒那么大。这个稍微大一点。它有三个房间外加一个门廊。它装在一个玻璃柜里，所以你可以从上面俯视房子的内部。他没有检查周围，直到他进入婴儿房。我想这里有很多空间。这个场景是一个可爱、维护良好的郊区住宅。
There are lace doils on the tables. Flower print linoleum in the kitchen. And blood everywhere. In the bedroom, a husband and wife are dead from gunshot wounds. In another room, a baby has been shot dead in her crib. Blood is spattered all over the pink wallpaper. It's a gruesome scene. The neighbor's dead. The neighbor was just supposed to be a murder suicide with him and his wife. blood is spattered all over the pink wallpaper. It's a gruesome scene.
桌上有蕾丝垫子。厨房里有花卉图案的油毡。到处都是血。在卧室里，丈夫和妻子死于枪伤。在另一个房间里，一个婴儿在婴儿床里被枪杀。血溅满了粉红色的墙纸。这是一个可怕的场景。邻居死了。邻居本应是一起他和妻子的谋杀自杀案。血溅满了粉红色的墙纸。这是一个可怕的场景。
The seminar that brought these folks here has been happening every year for the last 70 years. And the person who started it is the same person who made the little death scene dioramas. Her name was Frances Gllezznerly, and her work in the field of forensics has shaped just about everything that happens inside the office of the chief medical examiner in Baltimore, Maryland.
把这些人带到这里的研讨会过去70年来每年都在举办。而发起它的人正是制作这些微小死亡场景立体模型的人。她的名字叫弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李，她在法医领域的工作塑造了马里兰州巴尔的摩市首席法医办公室内部发生的一切。
To tell her story, I wanna introduce you to a couple of people. Medical examiner's office. Or you can call our investigations department and let me give you the first. That's Bruce Goldfarb. And I'm the executive assistant to the chief medical examiner for the state of Maryland. And this is Corinne.
为了讲述她的故事，我想向你们介绍几个人。法医办公室。或者你可以致电我们的调查部门，让我先介绍第一位。那是布鲁斯·戈德法布。我是马里兰州首席法医的行政助理。这位是科琳。
Hi, I'm Corinne Botz. I'm an artist in photographer. And I'm the author of the Nutchell Studies of Unexplained Death. Corinne spent seven years researching Francis Glezener Lee. So Francis Glezener Lee would have loved the opportunity to study medicine and go into college, but her parents were not supportive of that.
嗨，我是科琳·博茨。我是一名艺术家和摄影师。我是《未解之死的坚果壳研究》一书的作者。科琳花了七年时间研究弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李。所以，弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李本会很乐意有机会学习医学并上大学，但她的父母并不支持。
This was around 1900. Women weren't really going to medical school. Her brother got to go, though. Of course, and he brought a friend home once, a guy by the name of George McGrath, who was a pioneering medical examiner. McGrath and Lee became great friends, and when he'd come to visit, he'd tell her stories about cases he was working on. When she was just absolutely fascinating, she loved it.
那是在1900年左右。女性当时并不怎么去医学院。不过，她的哥哥可以去。当然，他有一次带了一个朋友回家，一个名叫乔治·麦格拉思的人，他是一位开创性的法医。麦格拉思和李成了好朋友，当他来访时，他会给她讲他正在处理的案件。她觉得这绝对令人着迷，她很喜欢。
Now Lee came from a wealthy Chicago family. She was supposed to be a proper society lady with lady hobbies, like needlework. So her interest in death wasn't really encouraged by her family, which meant for years she quietly studied it. She was a voracious reader, you know, talking to experts, getting first-hand experience by going to crime scenes. And then came to realize that people were getting away with murder, literally. Police would routinely botch investigations.
李来自芝加哥一个富裕的家庭。她本应是一位得体的名媛，有着淑女的爱好，比如针线活。所以她的家人并不鼓励她对死亡的兴趣，这意味着多年来她一直在悄悄地研究它。她是一个贪婪的读者，你知道，与专家交谈，通过去犯罪现场获得第一手经验。然后她开始意识到，人们真的在逍遥法外。警察会经常搞砸调查。
They would contaminate crime scenes, move bodies, do things that today would be obviously, you know, don't do that. But at the time they didn't know any better. And beyond that, the police just didn't know how to get information from these scenes. You know, they might not realize the significance of, you know, a pile of cigarettes or the positioning of a firearm. And the other thing was autopsies. Either weren't being done at all,
他们会污染犯罪现场，移动尸体，做一些今天看来显然是“不要那样做”的事情。但在当时，他们不知道更好的方法。不仅如此，警察根本不知道如何从这些现场获取信息。你知道，他们可能没有意识到一堆香烟或枪支位置的重要性。另一件事是尸检。要么根本没有进行，
or were being done by doctors with no specific training in forensics. Eventually Lee's parents and her brother passed away. She was in her 50s by then, and she finally had access to the family money and agency to do what she wanted. So in 1936. She gave a bunch of money to Harvard University
要么是由没有受过法医专业训练的医生进行的。最终，李的父母和哥哥去世了。那时她已经50多岁了，她终于有了使用家族资金和自主权去做她想做的事。所以，在1936年，她捐了一大笔钱给哈佛大学，
to establish the first program in legal medicine to train doctors and make them medical examiners. And then in 1945, Lee starts and presides over these week-long training seminars for police, the ones that are still going on today. She wanted to teach police, among other things, how to gather clues from a crime scene. Of course, in terms of the galleries and time constraints, they weren't actually able to visit a crime scene during the seminars. So, lead decides she'll build miniature death scenes
建立了第一个法律医学项目，以培训医生并使他们成为法医。然后在1945年，李开始主持这些为期一周的警察培训研讨会，这些研讨会至今仍在进行。她想教警察，除其他事项外，如何从犯罪现场收集线索。当然，考虑到画廊和时间限制，他们在研讨会期间实际上无法访问犯罪现场。所以，李决定她将建造微型死亡场景，
for the police to study. Each one will be based on a real death. She'll call them the nutshell studies of unexplained death. Basically, she would come up with the concept and the design, and her carpenter would drop the blueprints with a scale of an inch to a foot. Leigh's carpenter built the structures, framed the rooms exactly as you would a real life-size room.
供警察研究。每一个都将基于真实的死亡案例。她称它们为“未解之死的坚果壳研究”。基本上，她会提出概念和设计，她的木匠会以一英寸比一英尺的比例绘制蓝图。李的木匠建造了这些结构，像建造真实的真人大小房间一样精确地搭建了房间。
Real studs, real doors with real locks that worked. Leigh handled all the figures and the textiles, the rugs and drapes and tiny clothes on the tiny figures. Finally, those society-ladies' skills were being put to use. She would knit the stockings with needle-socies of straight pins using a magnifying glass, and of course, she could only work for like a few seconds before her eyes would fatigue. The figures in the nut shells also sometimes show rigor mortis, which is a post-mortem stiffening of the body, and levity, which is the way the blood pools or settles in the body after
真正的立柱，真正的门，带有真正能用的锁。李处理了所有的玩偶和纺织品、地毯、窗帘以及微小玩偶身上的微小衣服。终于，那些名媛的技能派上了用场。她会用放大镜用大头针编织长筒袜，当然，她只能工作几秒钟，眼睛就会疲劳。坚果壳里的玩偶有时也会表现出尸僵，即死后身体的僵硬，以及尸斑，即死后血液在体内积聚或沉淀的方式，
death, both provide clues as to how and when a person died. The detail in the nunchells is bordering unobstressive. In one, an ashtray overflows with tiny cigarettes made with real tobacco hand-rolled by Lee herself, each one burned and then stubbed out. The coffee pot she has, there's a strainer inside and coffee grounds in it. They're full of extraneous information because that's the way real life is. You know, you go into somebody's home, they could have a bag of drugs and a weapon over here and I have a heart attack. It may or may not mean anything.
两者都为一个人如何以及何时死亡提供了线索。坚果壳里的细节近乎执着。在一个场景中，烟灰缸里装满了微小的香烟，这些香烟是用李亲手卷的真烟草制成的，每一根都烧过然后掐灭。她有的咖啡壶里有一个过滤器，里面有咖啡渣。它们充满了无关紧要的信息，因为现实生活就是这样。你知道，你走进某人的家，他们可能有一袋毒品和一把武器在这里，而我心脏病发作了。这可能意味着什么，也可能什么都不意味着。
Francis Glezner Lee spared no expense on her dioramas. Like she sort of lavished love onto these brutal crime scenes. Each one took about six months and around $6,000 to build. That's about the same amount of time and money it would cost to build a real house in the 1940s. Leigh felt like if the policemen looked at them and saw any fault and didn't take them seriously, you know, they wouldn't learn from them so that's why she felt like everything had to be done perfectly. Of course, Frances Glasner Lee was always trying to be taken seriously in the all-male world
弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李在她的立体模型上不惜工本。她就像把爱倾注在这些残酷的犯罪现场上。每一个模型大约需要六个月的时间和大约6000美元来建造。这大约相当于20世纪40年代建造一栋真实房屋的时间和金钱。李觉得，如果警察看着它们并发现任何错误而不认真对待它们，你知道，他们就不会从中学习，所以这就是为什么她觉得一切都必须做得完美。当然，弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李一直试图在全男性的世界中被认真对待，
she had entered. She was ultimately both respected and adored by the police that she worked with. The week-long seminars she led were thought to be the best training homicide detectives could receive, and they're still thought of that way, actually, even today. After Francis Glezznerly died in 1962, the program she funded at Harvard, including the Wequong seminars were ended, and the nut shells were put in storage, possibly headed for the trash. And then the medical examiner in Baltimore at the time, a guy named Russell Fisher, who was a former student of Lee's programs at Harvard,
她进入了这个世界。她最终受到了她共事的警察的尊重和爱戴。她领导的为期一周的研讨会被认为是凶杀案侦探能接受的最好的培训，实际上，即使在今天，人们仍然这样认为。弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李于1962年去世后，她资助的哈佛大学项目，包括为期一周的研讨会，都被终止了，坚果壳模型被存放在仓库里，可能面临被扔掉的命运。然后，当时的巴尔的摩法医，一个名叫拉塞尔·费舍尔的人，他是李在哈佛项目的学生，
stepped in and said, we'll do it, we'll do the seminar. You know, we'll just pick it up here in Maryland and they brought the nut shells down. And so it's been the seminar and the nut shells have been used here since 1968. The building that houses the Medical Examiner's office in Baltimore is fairly new. It was built in 2010. Hello. Hello.
介入并说，我们会做，我们会举办研讨会。你知道，我们就在马里兰州接手，他们把坚果壳模型运了过来。所以自1968年以来，研讨会和坚果壳模型一直在这里使用。巴尔的摩法医办公室所在的建筑相当新。它建于2010年。你好。你好。
Bruce is giving me a tour of the building. It has some pretty unique features, including a full-size apartment that investigators can use to stage death scenes. Back behind us, we got a little dining area, kitchen. Bruce refers to it as a life-size nut shell study, and the most violent room in Baltimore. This is the most violent room in Baltimore. They also have a parking garage that, in an emergency,
布鲁斯正在带我参观大楼。它有一些非常独特的功能，包括一个调查员可以用来模拟死亡场景的真人大小的公寓。在我们身后，我们有一个小餐厅区、厨房。布鲁斯称之为真人大小的坚果壳研究，也是巴尔的摩最暴力的房间。这是巴尔的摩最暴力的房间。他们还有一个停车场，在紧急情况下，
can quickly turn into a huge morgue. And they have a biosafety facility to deal with death from highly contagious diseases. There's a whole isolation suite, and it has its own higher generation, its own ventilation, its own drainage. As we walk around the autopsy floor, the second floor, I'm on high alert. I'm basically terrified of running into something I'm not prepared to see or smell. You have to go through the decamper, if you want to stop and turn around, it's absolutely fine.
可以迅速变成一个巨大的停尸房。他们还有一个生物安全设施来处理高传染性疾病导致的死亡。有一个完整的隔离套房，它有自己的空气处理、通风和排水系统。当我们走在尸检楼层，即二楼时，我处于高度戒备状态。我基本上害怕遇到我没准备好看到或闻到的东西。如果你想停下来转身，完全没问题。
Wait, what am I going to have? I I'll see some stuff for all small things. Well, we'll hold it together, Mangle. Be cool. I know, totally not being cool. But we go through, and it's fine. I mean, yes, there are dead bodies. And I have many existential feelings about that that I won't share here.
等等，我会看到什么？我会看到一些小东西。好吧，我们要坚持住，明格尔。冷静点。我知道，完全没冷静下来。但我们走过去了，没问题。我的意思是，是的，有尸体。我对此有很多存在主义的感受，我不会在这里分享。
But mainly this place feels like a really clean hospital for dead people. It feels like, yeah, this is how it should be. Francis believed in science-based death investigation. The whole institution topped the bottom, I think is probably the fullest embodiment of her philosophy and her approach. Bruce is talking, of course, about Francis Glezner Lee. He says not only is this building an embodiment of her philosophies, but so is the whole Maryland system for dealing with death investigation.
但主要来说，这个地方感觉就像一个非常干净的死人医院。感觉就像，是的，这应该是这样。弗朗西斯相信基于科学的死亡调查。我认为整个机构从上到下可能是她哲学和方法的最充分体现。布鲁斯当然是在谈论弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李。他说，这座建筑不仅是她哲学的体现，整个马里兰州的死亡调查处理系统也是如此。
If you die unexpectedly in the state of Maryland, your death is likely to undergo a thorough investigation including an autopsy by a medical examiner with specific forensic training. But this is not what you get everywhere. Depending on where you die, you could end up in a facility like Maryland or you could literally end up on a makeshift table in someone's garage. From state to state and even county to county, there can be huge variations in quality. And there are definitely no federal regulations. There's a lot of substandard work.
如果你在马里兰州意外死亡，你的死亡很可能会经过彻底调查，包括由受过专门法医培训的法医进行尸检。但这并不是你在任何地方都能得到的。根据你死亡地点的不同，你可能会最终进入像马里兰州这样的设施，或者你可能真的最终躺在某人车库里的临时桌子上。从一个州到另一个州，甚至从一个县到另一个县，质量可能会有巨大的差异。而且绝对没有任何联邦法规。有很多不合格的工作，
Unfortunately, being done in that field, it's not like CSI. It's not like what you see on TV very often. That's AC Thompson. He did a bunch of reporting on this for pro-publica a few years ago. Very often, it's people working under dismal conditions for very little money with very little oversight. When someone dies in the U.S. and authority has to issue a death certificate with a cause of death.
不幸的是，在这个领域正在进行，它不像《CSI》。它不像你在电视上经常看到的那样。那是AC·汤普森。几年前，他为ProPublica对此做了大量报道。通常情况下，人们在恶劣的条件下工作，报酬很少，监管也很少。当某人在美国死亡时，当局必须签发一份带有死因的死亡证明。
If you die from an illness in hospital, this is something your doctor would do. If you die unexpectedly, like if you're murdered or a fall-downsmeep steps, a death certificate is issued by either a corner or a medical examiner. Maryland is on a medical examiner system. South Carolina, Colorado, and several other states are on coroner systems. And then you have states that are a weird mix of both, depending on what county you're in. In Francis Glezzarly was actually really passionate
如果你在医院因病死亡，这是你的医生会做的事情。如果你意外死亡，比如你被谋杀或从楼梯上摔下来，死亡证明由验尸官或法医签发。马里兰州实行法医系统。南卡罗来纳州、科罗拉多州和其他几个州实行验尸官系统。然后有些州是两者的奇怪混合，取决于你在哪个县。弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李实际上非常热衷于
about abolishing coroners in favor of medical examiners. Because, well, I don't know if she would have put it like this, but basically. The coroner system is crazy. It's bonkers, and it's an A-scientific thing from another era. First of all, you don't necessarily have to be a doctor to be a corner.
废除验尸官，转而支持法医。因为，嗯，我不知道她是否会这样说，但基本上。验尸官系统很疯狂。它很荒谬，是一个来自另一个时代的非科学的东西。首先，你不一定非得是医生才能成为验尸官。
That is to be the person who issues a death that you get with a cause of death. Like, I'm a high school graduate and a lot of places I could just roll out and say, ah, I'm running for a corner and be the county coroner. Now, I would typically work with an MD who would do the autopsy, but I'd be the one who would make the final decision.
也就是说，成为签发带有死因的死亡证明的人。比如，我是一个高中毕业生，在很多地方我可以直接站出来说，啊，我要竞选验尸官，然后成为县验尸官。现在，我通常会与一名进行尸检的医学博士合作，但我将是做出最终决定的人。
And that's the other thing. The coroner is an elected office. When you have medical professionals or even non-medical professionals who have to run for office based on what happens in the morgue, hmm, sets up potential conflicts of interest. One of the situations where you might see conflicts of interest are cases where someone dies in police custody. AC actually did some reporting on this very thing in New Orleans. And what you see
这就是另一件事。验尸官是一个民选职位。当你拥有必须根据停尸房发生的事情竞选职位的医疗专业人员甚至非医疗专业人员时，嗯，这会产生潜在的利益冲突。你可能会看到利益冲突的情况之一是有人在警察拘留期间死亡的案件。AC实际上在新奥尔良报道过这件事。你所看到的
in New Orleans over and over and over again is that when people died in police custody or when people died in jail custody, there would be pretty good evidence that something untoward had happened. They'd been neglected, they'd been severely beaten, they'd been attacked, and what was happening was the corner there was basically trying to pretend that these things didn't happen. He was ruling deaths to be accidental that should have been ruled as homicides. His name was Frank Mimmyard. He actually was a doctor, but he wasn't trained as a medical
在新奥尔良，一次又一次地发生，当人们在警察拘留期间死亡或在监狱拘留期间死亡时，会有相当好的证据表明发生了不当行为。他们被忽视了，他们被严重殴打，他们被袭击了，而发生的事情是那里的验尸官基本上试图假装这些事情没有发生。他将本应被裁定为他杀的死亡裁定为意外。他的名字叫弗兰克·米米亚德。他实际上是一名医生，但他没有受过法医培训。
examiner. He was an OB-GYN, and he seemed to have a bias toward protecting the police. Maybe because he constantly had to campaign to keep his job. Who does he want to endorse him? Well he wants the police to endorse him. And if he's got a big spat with the police, is that going to look good for voters? In New Orleans, the FBI finally stepped in and did some of their own investigations and some police did eventually go to jail for some of those deaths.
他是一名妇产科医生，他似乎有一种保护警察的偏见。也许是因为他必须不断竞选以保住工作。他想让谁支持他？嗯，他想让警察支持他。如果他和警察发生了大争执，这对选民来说好看吗？在新奥尔良，FBI最终介入并进行了一些他们自己的调查，一些警察最终确实因为其中一些死亡事件而入狱。
But Minnard was never fired by the voters or anyone else. He served as coroner for 40 years and finally retired in 2014. So it's worth noting when you're talking about incidents involving the police, that if the police shoots somebody, the coron medical examiner is gonna say, it was a homicide, you can't really get around that. And then the question will be, is it justified or not? But then there are cases that are less gut and dry.
但米米亚德从未被选民或任何人解雇。他担任验尸官40年，最终于2014年退休。所以值得注意的是，当你谈论涉及警察的事件时，如果警察射杀了某人，验尸官会说，这是一起他杀，你真的无法绕过这一点。然后问题将是，它是正当的还是不正当的？但也有一些案件不那么简单明了。
And those are the ones where an impartial, scientific death investigation might matter the most. And actually while I was in Baltimore, one of these cases was playing out, you probably heard about it. For a second day in Baltimore, a demand for answers into how 25-year-old Freddie Gray suffered a fatal spinal cord injury while in police custody. Freddie Gray sustained his fatal injury on April 12th.
而这些正是公正、科学的死亡调查可能最重要的地方。实际上，当我在巴尔的摩时，其中一个案件正在上演，你可能听说过。在巴尔的摩的第二天，人们要求查明25岁的弗雷迪·格雷在警察拘留期间是如何遭受致命脊髓损伤的。弗雷迪·格雷在4月12日受了致命伤。
He died a week later on the 19th. And for days after his death, people protested and waited to see if the state's attorney, Marilyn Mosby, would bring charges against the police involved in the incident. And Mosby was waiting too. She was waiting to see how the medical examiner would rule the death. As soon as she got their findings, she made her announcement. The findings of our comprehensive, thorough and independent investigation coupled with the medical examiner's determination
他一周后的19日去世了。在他死后的几天里，人们抗议并等待州检察官玛丽琳·莫斯比是否会对参与该事件的警察提出指控。莫斯比也在等待。她正在等待法医如何裁定死亡。一旦她得到他们的调查结果，她就发表了声明。我们全面、彻底和独立的调查结果，加上法医的裁定，
that Mr. Gray's death was a homicide, which we received today, has led us to believe that we have probably caused to file criminal charges. So, so, so, so. We don't know if the officers charged in Fertig Freddie Gray's death will be convicted, but they were charged, and for a lot of people, this was an important first step. I had left Baltimore by the time the medical examiner's office released their findings on Freddie Gray, but I have to say that having just been there and seen the way they do
即格雷先生的死亡是一起他杀，我们今天收到了这一裁定，这使我们相信我们可能有理由提出刑事指控。所以，所以，所以，所以。我们不知道被指控导致弗雷迪·格雷死亡的警官是否会被定罪，但他们确实被指控了，对许多人来说，这是一个重要的第一步。当法医办公室发布关于弗雷迪·格雷的调查结果时，我已经离开了巴尔的摩，但我必须说，刚刚去过那里并看到了他们做事的方式，
things, I felt pretty confident in their process. It felt like their findings would be based in science and not tied to politics. And I don't think it's a stretch to say that Frances Gvesner Lee had something to do with that. If she were to walk around, see what we do, how we do things here, I think she'd be very pleased. And you know, she really is, I don't know if we believe in guiding spirit, so that sort of thing, but she is very definitely a
我对他们的程序非常有信心。感觉他们的调查结果将基于科学，而不是与政治挂钩。我认为说弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李与此有关并不夸张。如果她走来走去，看看我们做什么，我们在这里做事的方式，我想她会非常高兴。而且你知道，她确实是，我不知道我们是否相信引导精神，那种东西，但她绝对是
presence here every day. At the end of the Francis Glezzner Lee seminar and homicide investigation, the attendees present their theories about what happened in each of their nutshell studies, and then they get to find out the actual solutions. Was it a homicide stage to look like a suicide, or a suicide stage to look like a homicide, or something else entirely? This is the folder that contains the solutions to the nut shells. The guy that has the answers to these questions might be the most Baltimore guy I met in Baltimore.
每天在这里的存在。在弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李凶杀案调查研讨会结束时，与会者展示了他们关于每个坚果壳研究中发生了什么的理论，然后他们会发现实际的解决方案。这是一起伪装成自杀的他杀，还是伪装成他杀的自杀，还是完全其他的事情？这是包含坚果壳解决方案的文件夹。拥有这些问题答案的人可能是我在巴尔的摩遇到的最“巴尔的摩”的人。
Hi, my name is Jerry Jetsch. You have also known as Jerry Day. Sometimes the police will come up with their own solution. And since they're all wearing guns, I don't challenge them to say you're wrong. I just say that's not how Frances saw it, but I do have the answers. Jerry D is not going to let me see the folder or record when he tells the solutions. They guard the nutshell secrets like the recipe for Coke or the code for the Google search algorithm because they're still valuable secrets. As long as the solutions aren't easily searchable, the nut shells are still great tools
嗨，我的名字是杰里·杰奇。你也被称为杰里·戴。有时警察会提出他们自己的解决方案。既然他们都带着枪，我不会挑战他们说你错了。我只是说那不是弗朗西斯看到的方式，但我确实有答案。杰里·戴不会让我看文件夹或记录他讲述解决方案的过程。他们像可口可乐配方或谷歌搜索算法代码一样守护着坚果壳的秘密，因为它们仍然是宝贵的秘密。只要解决方案不容易搜索到，坚果壳仍然是很好的工具，
for teaching homicide investigation. And that is something that the Medical Examiner's Office in Baltimore, Maryland, especially Bruce Goldfarb for letting us come to visit. Corinne Botz's book, The Nut Shell Studies of Unexplained Death, is full of amazing photographs of the nut shells, some of which you can see on our website is99pi.org. Being that this is the 70th anniversary, in order to celebrate,
用于教授凶杀案调查。这就是马里兰州巴尔的摩市法医办公室，特别是布鲁斯·戈德法布让我们来参观的事情。科琳·博茨的书《未解之死的坚果壳研究》里充满了坚果壳的精美照片，其中一些你可以在我们的网站is99pi.org上看到。鉴于这是70周年纪念，为了庆祝，
we've actually had a 70th anniversary challenge coin made with Francis Gersnerley on the back, and the Harvard Associates on the front. Yep, Katie got a Francis Gersnerley challenge coin made with Frances Guizmeli on the back and the Harvard Associates on the front. Yep, Katie got a Frances Glusner Lee challenge coin when she was there and every is so jealous. Make sure you coin check Katie when you're here. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Sam Greenspan Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine,
我们实际上制作了一枚70周年纪念挑战币，背面是弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李，正面是哈佛协会。是的，凯蒂在去那里时得到了一枚弗朗西斯·格莱斯纳·李挑战币，每个人都非常嫉妒。当你在这里时，一定要检查凯蒂的硬币。本周的《99%隐形》由凯蒂·明格尔与萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的Arxine建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作，
an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible. You must go to 999pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《99%隐形》。你必须去99pi.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。